[Music]
was work this fun before the pandemic
several firms have posted videos online
like this one from semiconductor firm
global foundries in dresden with staff
singing dancing and having fun amid the
pandemic
but weather activities like this really
help boost happiness or make up for the
isolation or challenges of working from
home is yet to be seen i'm ben fazel and
welcome to the show
scientists would call it survival of the
fittest well some of us have been
fighting for our lives in this pandemic
others have been battling loneliness
both take a certain amount of physical
and mental fitness in the ugandan
capital kampala we met a musician with a
unique survival strategy
meet easy uganda's emerging dancehall
artist finally in 2020 the 22 year old
was set to release his first album and
then the covert 19 pandemic struck i was
still trying to lay down the basics
coffee turns up
lockdown stopped all social activities
in kampala music performances easy's
major income generator became illegal
but one night under the pressure of
covert 19 blues easy had an idea
i woke up with a rhythm in my head and
i'm like
[Music]
it was the nirvana of tumbiza sound
easy's breakthrough song the track shuns
the worries of the pandemic and it
became uganda's lockdown anthem
soon with the help from ugandan
tick-tockers and influencers like
kampala's h2c dancers the song went
viral with over 2 million views on
youtube and became a remedy for
depressed moods
but the song's popularity attracted
unwanted attention the ugandan
government banned it claiming easy was
inciting the public to party in the
middle of a pandemic
easy would later be ordered to explain
himself undaunted he asked the
authorities to take it easy
in the song
i was speaking of covid
and
basically saying
our hearts grew strong
we are not scared of it anymore if we
have to have sanitizers we'll get them
we have to have face masks we will get
them but it doesn't stop you from being
happy forget your problems yeah
but the publicity of being banned shot
easy and tombiza sound to stardom and
now that he's finally off the hook he
can enjoy every moment
from cursing the disastrous pandemic to
making the musical cure for it easy has
a message for young people however bad
the situation might be it doesn't stop
at that you will rise
well it's crises like this one that
often drive innovation but just how
innovative have we been in this pandemic
a lot of us have learned how to go
digital but a lot of us including many
companies and countries are still
struggling to do just that
here's derek williams with another of
your questions on the coronavirus
pandemic
israel was testing for covet at
mcdonald's drive-throughs what are some
other innovative ideas for tackling the
pandemic
crises force us to find solutions and
the pandemic
has driven innovation in a huge number
of ways in a really vast range of fields
off the top of my head
your comment about fast food restaurants
in israel also serving up
vaccines reminded me of of a recent
event that took place here in berlin
when public transport authorities turned
a train
into a mobile vaccination center
so many showed up to get shots that a
lot of people had to be left behind
on the platform
robots and drones are also being used a
lot in innovative ways to fight the
pandemic for example like these in
indonesia that have been used to deliver
food and medicines to homes and to ships
where covet 19 patients are in isolation
but for me by far the greatest
innovation during the pandemic has been
the rapid development and approval and
and deployment of messenger rna vaccines
um the incredibly promising technology
isn't new um we've been working on it
for decades but but until now
it had remained
tantalizingly out of reach and and then
the pandemic caused us
to really hit the gas on them and and
mrna platforms
have finally arrived
in the future they'll allow us to to
react to changes
in mutating pathogens
with tweaks to vaccines a lot more
cheaply and a lot more rapidly
and they can even be designed to attack
non-infectious diseases like cancer
so if there's a silver lining to covid19
it's it's that in the future
the mrna vaccines develop to fight it
and what they teach us will save many
many more lives
far beyond the pandemic
[Music]
here's a look at a couple of other
stories making news during this
coronavirus pandemic u.s drug maker
merck and co says its covert antiviral
pill
mole new pirava can reduce the risk of
hospitalization or death by 50 percent
that's according to findings of an
interim analysis of a late stage trial
the treatment if approved by authorities
could give doctors more tools to fight
covert
being closed for nearly 300 days beaches
in the cuban capital havana have
reopened authorities gave the green
light for resuming outdoor activities
with most of the city's residents
vaccinated against covert 19.
beaches and pools can now operate at
limited capacity along with bars and
restaurants
italy has become the first european
country to mandate covert 19 health
passes for all workers
in future employees will need to have a
so-called green pass or be suspended
from their jobs without pay
they'll also have the option of showing
a negative test which they'll have to
pay for the government hopes the measure
will see more people get vaccinated
italy's government taking tough measures
to combat covert 19. from next month it
will be mandatory for all workers in
public and private sectors to get a
health pass users will have to show
proof of vaccination a negative test or
recovery from infection
the green pass is an instrument of
freedom that makes places safer secondly
the green pass makes our vaccination
campaign more effective
on the streets of rome there's a mixed
reaction to the announcement
the green pass is an important tool to
deal with this serious situation in such
a serious situation we need effective
solutions
in my opinion it's not fair because i am
a free citizen i can decide whether or
not to get a green pass when there's an
obligation we no longer live in a
democracy but a dictatorship so i don't
agree
italy is the first country in europe to
implement the covert 19 green pass for
all workers originally it was set up to
ease travel restrictions and give access
to indoor venues authorities now say
expanding the measures will help the
vaccination uptake stop infections and
prevent further lockdowns those who
ignore the decree could face fines up to
1 000 euros but persuading everyone to
get inoculated may be challenging the
country has seen protests in recent
weeks including at various railway
stations
italy was one of the worst hit by the
coronavirus pandemic last year more than
130 000 people died
while around 74
of the population have received at least
one covert 19 shot it's a delicate
balancing act for authorities now to
prevent a repeat of the past as winter
approaches
australia plans to reopen its borders to
international travelers prime minister
scott morrison announced the decision
saying that the restrictions will be
lifted once the country reaches an 80
vaccination rate however travelers will
be required to be fully vaccinated and
to adhere to quarantine requirements
once they enter the country national
carrier qantas airways has always also
announced it will be resuming some
international flights starting next
month
for the last 18 months standing in line
for an international flight was an
experience very few australians were
allowed
australia shut its borders keeping out
non-citizens but also blocking most
australian citizens from around the
world from going home
as part of a policy to stop coronavirus
cases being brought in from abroad the
government limited the number of people
allowed to enter australia each month
those allowed in had to quarantine and
specially designated hotels for two
weeks
and pay the bills themselves
the policy helped keep covert 19 cases
low for months
but it could not stop outbreaks of the
delta variant in major cities in july
this year
now as more people are vaccinated prime
minister scott morrison is lifting some
of those restrictions from november
it's time to give australians their
lives back that will be able to open
those international borders again
and that will enable australians who are
fully vaccinated
and australians and residents of
australia who are overseas who are fully
vaccinated to be able to travel again
once 80 percent of the state's
population is vaccinated
vaccinated citizens will be allowed to
fly abroad
quotas limiting the number of people
allowed into the country will be lifted
and fully vaccinated australians will be
able to quarantine at home for seven
days
the airline quantus will start flying
internationally in mid-november
and for australians with the jab
travel abroad could be within reach
and we leave you with these next
pictures one of the biggest global
events since the start of the pandemic
reopening in dubai
nearly 200 countries are taking part in
expo 2020 which was delayed for a year
because of the coronavirus restrictions
dubai hopes the 6 billion euro fare will
attract new business european parliament
has urged nations not to take part
citing human rights abuses in dubai and
the government's use of spyware critics
also questioned how many workers fell
ill with covert during the construction